this just feel a little extreme Risa
breaking the law on everything you want
to go to jail I'm not ready to be a
lesbian yet Maresa did you even remember
to apply for college I know things can
get hard for you yeah they do
they're called dips Kelly I cannot
believe these be friends with those
girls they're so dusty looking I want to
throw the party favorite friendship
signs and you know I want to get that
funeral idiots you want to [ __ ] these
kids up tonight Oh God
we're just gonna figure out where the
party is tonight meets who I asked him
dude you just called me a boner this
party could be anywhere and nowhere at
the same time why don't we just let
these kids have their moment this is my
moment it is the last day of school you
were not an even sale inappropriate
language offensive clothing the verdict
for both of us detention once you please
take that bow no I won all right our
rules are protector and kill and open
the window but they're painted shut
rumor has it the last counselor left to
her death
I love you guys so much you're my best
friends there's one one way to do this
[Music]
that's the pace in which they're gonna
[ __ ] you in the air in prison right
Jesus take a lot brother [ __ ] [ __ ]
dick in your butt
it never stops
[Music]
you